bacon is good for me thinking the best I
was born for bacon I don't actually like
bacon doesn't like bacon
so so on sushi I don't think sushi can
be improved by bacon I actually expect
this to be bad
what just gravity you don't have the
skills and this looks like McDonald's
bacon it's so good I'm not into it I'm
happy might have ruined bacon for me a
little bit it's like a breakfast sushi
roll pretty good the sushi overpowers
the bacon
it certainly doesn't need it
I'm into that
it's might be very weird oh that smells
really good it does look like maple
syrup oh man this is scary ill smoother
but it's not like the flavor of bacon
the fat really dulls the flavor of
everything a little trendy for me
Oh Ally bananas to be a good person I
love bananas
mmm it kind of smells like like
breakfast kind of smelled like pancakes
I'm pretty this is gonna taste like yeah
yep god it looks so good
this is Guinea it's getting the whole
tongue this sweet and salty yeah as a
mommy thing going on there isn't it
enough of this in the world I do that
look at the end of most drunk nights I
just want to make bacon anyway Cheers
whoo that is good
you taste sorry that like makes it just
easier to drink it's putting hair on my
chest makes it more special than the
average Friday night whiskey this is
making me question everything life's got
you down to take a swig from that bacon
whiskey if you're willing to get drunk
why not get drunk off bacon I'm drunk
already I like it I love it
I'll do some more of it I just want you
to know this is a very special time in
my life and I'm just so glad I could be
sharing it with you uh with you yeah I
am in mind speaking in love with bacon
making love